Donald Trump leave him alone Trump
responds to classified documents found
at Mike's Pence's residence he never did
anything knowingly dishonest in his life
Trump took to his social media site
truth social defending the former vice
president Mike Pence is an innocent man
he never did anything knowingly
dishonest in his life with Malone I
think he's being sarcastic is that the
point I don't know so so I guarantee you
Chris Bertman wrote this story for those
just tuning in uh Diddy yeah uh yes he
did for those just tuning in
um they found documents at Mike Pence's
house and it's like okay
um
why at this point you know a nuanced Pro
is making the point how come this is
happening now with everybody Trump gets
hit he gets raided now the doj is
searching Biden's house now they're
searching Pence's house is this is like
the military finally or the doj the
executive branch some Cuda Tower they're
probably like let's just get rid of
anybody who's got any any executive
chances the president the former
president the vice president we just are
all gone they're not going to be able to
prosecute any of this stuff what
happened to Hillary when we found stuff
nothing but we weren't supposed to
nothing at all interesting right nothing
and Hillary was in no position to
declassify anything she wasn't even in
the executive branch she was well she
was a you know member of state but you
know it's a good question you asked why
is this all these why is it happen to
all these people right now like why do
you think yeah well I mean did you see
the other story about the uh the FBI guy
who was leading the investigation was
colluding with Russia yeah like he leads
the Russia investigation against Trump
and then they're like oh yeah he was
we're charging him for colluding with
Russia like there's so something going
on I don't know what it is I don't know
if it's like the Deep State trying to
get rid of Biden but in like a weird way
where they're like oh but like there's
other people we're trying we're Fair
maybe trying to re-establish their uh
you know their uh their reputation with
the American public I I don't know what
it is I mean I suppose that makes sense
if the if the if the Department of
Justice was going to go ahead and say
all right let's start trying to fix our
image because we've allowed it to be
tarnished so bad and and the American
people don't trust the deal no I don't
think they would be doing it like
legitimately like this would be like the
the veil under which they say like oh
see we're hitting everybody but they
have a bigger agenda potentially at play
where maybe they they're not so happy
with Biden and they want to get rid of
them I I have no idea like in that case
if they don't want bite anymore who do
they want
I have some someone who can win someone
who doesn't have their wishes and
pulling out of Afghanistan maybe Newsome
I just don't know news I think newsom's
the guy is my I think Newton's the guy
that the Democrats are going to be look
look if you were a deep state cabal
conspiracy villain and you wanted
someone to fit the mold of you know like
puppet Machiavellian you know Manchurian
Candidate like newsom's your guy I mean
look at him he looks like he's probably
a lizard person you know he's American
Psycho he is American Psycho exactly so
you're sitting there and you're like
look I'm evil and trying to rule the
world this guy looks like he fits them
all he's like a young Bond Villain Like
Cloud Schwab is the old Bond villain but
like he's like the number two you know
he could be he could be the one villain
he could do it there's a comic book
character that he reminds me of I don't
I don't remember the comic book
character's name it was a tertiary
character but it was the just the the
way that the hair was that they kind of
flew back like pointy and he would shoot
uh ice from his hands kind of like guys
I don't remember who the guy was but
that'd be cool if if Newsom could shoot
ice from his hands I might vote for him
I mean he could fix the uh that you're
out there having in in California and
global warming oh that's true I actually
met him when I was a kid I was a I was
at the mall in San Francisco and he's
just like sitting there on his phone and
I'm like a little kid I'm like mayor
Newsom and he's like yeah
and I was like he shoots you with ice
he's like can I help you and he's like
okay and he goes back on his phone I
went and watched the movies for like
four hours and I come back and he's
still walking how old were you I don't
remember it was a while back but uh he
was not very nice but I met uh the other
mayor of San Francisco Willie Brown that
guy was super nice uh that was the guy
who like hooked up with Kamala Harris by
the way yeah I mean oh really yeah yeah
I mean he was he was getting it he was
he was probably in good moves he seemed
like a happy guy yeah it was probably
around that time actually maybe good for
the vice president how do you feel about
London breed how's she doing
um I feel like every day someone is I
mean listen it's San Francisco you have
to you know you go with what you get I
mean she's better than chess of Boudin
who was the AG who got recalled
um but I don't know she's still not
great she's still like she just goes
with whatever the political wins are in
San Francisco you know she was for
defunding the police then when she was
like oh that's unpopular even with San
Francisco okay no I never I never did
that that's not I didn't support that at
all so is it unpopular in San Francisco
it is yeah really like that's why they
recalled uh Chessa Boudin was Chester
Boudin with the one with uh Weather
Underground ties yeah that was the one
where his biological parents were put in
prison for like a Brinks bank robbery
back in the day and then his biological
I mean then his uh his uh godparents uh
who I guess raised him that raised him
were uh Bernadine Dorne and Bill Ayers
who were the founders of like yeah
they're underground but there's nothing
to see here don't worry yeah yeah don't
worry he's totally just like one of
those normal antifa communist types but
he's your local yeah
so are we are we 90 seconds to midnight
because the country is going to implode
on itself no like the the well well hold
on you know don't don't jump the gun too
soon here's what I'm saying you you
asked why it was that all of a sudden
we're seeing documents about Mike Pence
could it be that the political divide is
inside our uh executive branch
um
so this is what I said in 2018
I was saying that I think we're on the
track towards the Civil War and it
wasn't because one day I just said it
was because I was reading the Atlantic
or something and they were like all
these security actors around the world
fear the Civil War is possible in the
United States the aggregate estimate is
like 35 chance over the next 10 years
and I was like Wow and then I looked at
the points they were saying and I said
with the escalation of the of the
political conflict on the streets with
the bifurcation of world view and I'm
like yeah it seems like sooner or later
this happens and I had a bunch of
conservatives be like no it could never
happen the security state would never
allow it and then I'm like my guy
what happens when the security state is
is impacted by the very same cultural
divide and the same worldview divide
what happens when you have the DC Bureau
of the FBI very pro-democrat raid Donald
Trump and then you get a Florida Bureau
who is pissed off and so they say you
could this is this is BS so then they
say you know what we're going to file
and we're going to raid Biden's house or
somebody in Delaware does and then then
you get the DC Bureau again being like
they're going to come after Biden we're
going after Pence and it's what's
happening is inside the doj they're
going Tit for Tat back and forth with
their political enemies yeah I mean this
is an exciting interesting idea that I
would kind of hope is actually going on
Matt saibi wrote a few years ago that we
were close to this this thing he called
the arrest that I think he called it the
arrest that man phase or I don't want to
misquote Matt but he was basically
saying that he's seen in other countries
where you get to the point where two
black vehicles with government officials
they they speed Off full speed driving
and waving through the streets they both
pull up to the chief of police they both
jump out of the car and yell officer
arrested that man at each other
and that's what it feels like we're
getting to with this yeah why would the
doj go after the former president the
former vice president and the sitting
president and Hunter Biden's being
investigated too and everybody's saying
what could this be is the Deep State
trying to get rid of Joe Biden yo what
if I'll tell you this I've talked to
people who work in intelligence and and
I've had them say you got to understand
it's the same everywhere as it as it's
the same in here as it is everywhere
else I've had uh there's a guy I met
I won't say too much but a couple guys
of different intelligence agencies and
and you know
that I get emails from people and they
say hey Tim I work here let me tell you
what's going on I've met people in
person they say hey look here's where I
work here's what's happening and I'm
like why are we seeing this this heavy
bias from the doj from the FBI like why
are they arresting pro-life activists
but ignoring the protesters in front of
Brett Kavanaugh's house what I'm told
paraphrasing the gist of it is it's the
exact same the based off uh agents are
scared to speak up and actually move on
the far left because they'll get fired
they'll get canceled and there's there's
higher up elements that they believe our
walk will come after them so they're
like the Divide is the same everywhere
it's the same in here so there are a
bunch of cops who are a bunch of FBI
agents intelligence guys who are you
know pro-trump or Maga or conservative
or libertarian but they won't speak up
what if now we're actually seeing a seat
of power where the the DC Bureau I think
it's the DC Bureau of the D of the FBI
is the ones that have been really
heavy-handed went after Donald Trump
after Mar-A-Lago what if now we're
finally seeing some
FBI agents be brave and say we're going
to go to Biden so we're going to
actually do our jobs so are you saying
it's time like it's likely that mayor
Garland will get removed I mean what is
the shift here because mayor mayor
Garland theoretically is at the center
of this idea I'm saying
my understanding is that these these
branches all operate relatively
independently like they have a there is
a centralization there's some Authority
but it's not like some dude in Omaha is
calling up DC and let him know that
they're going to go arrest a guy who is
no no like they handled on their own
they go to their their District Court
they go to the states the U.S courts and
things like that to a certain degree
they have autonomy they're expected to
to operate
my understanding is that you know there
there are people who are in these
agencies or in the FBI or in the doj who
do think Biden's corrupt who do think
that Hunter by the script that they're
doing these illicit deals but no one has
the balls to do anything I don't know
maybe project Veritas got to him maybe
James O'Keefe constantly saying be brave
maybe the FBI whistleblowers who came to
James O'Keefe finally started inspiring
some people at the mid-level who are
like
we're gonna go take a look at the
president's house now that being said it
was it was Biden's aides and lawyers who
discovered and then released the
documents but it very well may be the
reason they're pursuing the search is
because there are people who are finally
like I'm done with this I'm gonna start
going into it and then why does pence
get hit
I wouldn't be surprised if it's because
the corruption is it's they're now
saying okay we're going after you we're
going to one up and go after your guys
sure and I also wondered with uh Biden's
release like if his aides are finding
them are they just trying to get out
ahead of it like it looks chaotic to us
but like was there another threatened
play where they're like well we have to
be the ones to say that we found
documents from our house I just want to
say that's the most white pilling story
that I've heard in ages I love the idea
of the government going after the
government
maybe but I don't I don't see as a white
pill moment no I want to clarify it was
Biden's team who notified the doj the
documents it was Pence's team who
notified the FBI of the documents so
maybe it's just
these guys are
I don't know so do we wait for Obama to
also be like ah as it turns out I too
have some documents like and then Bill
Clinton stands up I also have documents
and then drugs and bushes I do too and
then they all like stand together like
you know I'm smart can't take us all
that's what they're saying I think they
should take them all they're surrounding
Trump even Biden is I am Spartacus
Trump's like he's got a tear in his eyes
like thank you guys and they're like you
come for one of us you come for us all
they would never defend you look I don't
know I just think it's possible that we
do get to the point and this to me
doesn't sound like a white pill I don't
think it's a black pill either but we
have to come to a certain point where
either
like I mentioned the FBI is arresting
pro-life activists in their homes yeah
ignoring protesters in front of judges
homes which is also illegal and the same
capacity of illegal protesting here's
illegal protesting here's illegal
they're only going One Direction
certainly at some point there's going to
be a guy in the FBI who's like I am done
I'm filing the paperwork you're under
arrest
yeah I mean it could also be uh
positioning for future administrations I
mean if you're in a political position
in the FBI currently under a democratic
Administration
um you know when a new Administration
comes in and they want a clean house
potentially in the executive branch and
they you know replace Ag and everything
uh or they place you know the head of
the OJ like you know
that you could be the person being like
hey I'm the one who went after Biden in
his documents even under a democratic
Administration like I'm the legit
principled guy you can still keep me
around I don't know it there could be
something they're jumping off this
sinking ship kind of thing maybe I don't
know
yeah man look
10 years ago we had gamergate
you had a bunch of like left liberal
internet personalities
and they were called far right and all
that stuff and then you you get the the
the the the the ignition of the culture
War the culture War had been happening
to a certain degree Loosely and then
finally it like kicks off with with
gamergate and now
10 years ago
there were teenagers they were 16 years
old when this stuff was happening and
they were online and thought it was
funny and they were on one side of the
other these people are now 26 years old
they are now the interns working at some
of these big corporations or
intelligence agencies or government or
Congressional offices or at scotus or at
scotus leaking documents
10 years from now they will be in their
mid-30s and they will be the mid to
higher level managers and and they're in
your mid-30s we're talking CEOs we're
talking members of Congress we're
talking
people in state government and they are
going to be in the culture War so that
bifurcation that happened and that split
as people get older the split is going
to be hitting every level of our of our
culture government production
infrastructure and when we get to the
point where the Boomers have let's just
call it aged out
no longer voting no longer having an
impact on our society and it's gen xers
holding desperately on to keep things
together sorry you got Millennials you
got gen Z and then you're gonna have the
young gen Alpha coming in to vote and
they are all going to be in in Universe
1 and universe a I watched a video where
a drag queen performed for teenagers at
high school and everyone's clapping like
this and they're wiggling little sticks
in the air and I'm like that's a
completely different Universe like the
people who watch this show the people
who are like the people who watch
crowded people who watch Daily wire you
know to ignite that controversy but the
people who watch this space
would not be clapping and cheering
watching drag queens in lewd outfits
perform for children but to them they
like it it's normal I'm like two
completely different worlds well
literally there was that video of like a
little toddler like shooting his pistol
or whatever and people were like oh
you're not okay with like kids doing
drag shows but you are okay with this
you're pushing uh that was one of the
most insane discourses on Twitter that
I've seen in a lot it's like two con two
countries exist already it's just not
obvious that they have completely
separated in that example they were
calling it grooming it's like he's
teaching his son like basic gun safe
it's so crazy and when you call it when
you try to call that kind of stuff
grooming and you obfuscate the fact that
there is actual Google
obfuscate child rape but but like
there's no two ways about that like it's
not you can't say oh well it's grooming
this kid because he's showing you how to
properly handle a gun blah blah and then
be like that's not distracting from the
fact that there is actual child but this
is the thing they don't care they don't
they don't they have no moral there's a
basis for any other perspective they
don't there's a meme and it's Kyle
Rittenhouse and Greta tunberg and it
says their youth are not like our youth
and you know the funny thing about that
Meme is the left and the right both
share it in the exact same way on
ironically it's the only uniting thing
the other one is uh that there were some
15 year old who like protested a uh LGBT
Rally or something with like holding a
crucifix and the police carried him off
like he's hands feet and they put it
next to the one like we just we just
want to see what's happening here insane
I mean just the just the way that you
know I I don't want to beat a dead horse
about right now but just the way the
writtenhouse was classified is
completely insane people still talk
about Rittenhouse as if he was you know
he's he's guilty of of aggressive murder
it's it's ridiculous I mean did you see
that story this is to your earlier point
about uh that gay couple that like they
adopted yeah like so like you know
people were talking about that story and
then the reactions I saw from certain
people who you know supposedly on the
right like this is two part people in
particular but like their first reaction
no no their first reaction was to post
like oh look but here's a photo of a
little girl at a Hooters like if you're
not as like how come the people who
oppose this never talk about this it's
like if that's your first reaction is to
pull up what about ISM when a story
about a gay couple raping their adoptive
kids and again that's very sub it's rape
it's like oh we're going to get food at
Hooters and we're gonna compare it with
rape what are you talking about that's
not it's insane I wanna I wanna mention
the Hooters thing too because it's like
we talk about grooming with these people
dancing in lewd outfits for children and
it's like look man I don't think you
should bring your kids to Hooters
because it's it's like it's kind of low
brow but there's a big difference
between the women there are wearing
shirts and shorts okay that like you can
see their cleavage but women wear those
things in public all the time they walk
around doing that that that is a social
Norm that you might be like well you
know I don't like my kids around that
stuff but people do it everywhere I
would recommend not bringing your kid to
Hooters but um the fact that women have
a body shape and wear you know I don't
even want to call them skimpy I would
necessarily it's not they're wearing
bikinis or anything they're wearing
shorts and form fitting right
not appropriate for kids in my opinion
at the same time very different from a
strip show very very different from
having a drag queen strip in front of
children or having children strip for
them at a gay bar which they've been
doing or what was the literally sex
clowns like drag queens are sex clowns
that's what they are they're they're
sexualized clowns like they're they're
the whole burlesque
it's like crossover between it's like
it's like LGBT burlesque yeah and you
know jenkuger put out this tweet and he
was like if I had the money I'd put on
the biggest drag show and my first
thought was like you do have the money
saying he does not that expensive I mean
you could do it for a couple Grand my
attitude is like dude I'll put on a big
drag show this'd be awesome we'll go to
local theater we'll do a big drag show
we'll get some of the best drag queens
we'll invite you know everybody will do
free food free drinks of course with the
drinks dress and drag for that 21 20
minutes
because it's for adults and uh I have no
issue with adults wanting to do
entertainment silly funny things like
this or whatever they want to do it's
the weird thing that they're going after
kids but anyway my ultimately to bring
it back to the we're talking about the
classified documents the point is two
clearly different realities and if
you've got people right now
that you were you're we're at the point
where we are actually watching these
people have children strip on stage at
gay bars this was there was a young boy
I'm not gonna say his name because his
family's litigious he's ripping his
clothes off and dancing around and
they're giving him money I'm like that's
what stripping is okay you can call go
go dancing you can call it stripping
call bikini bars whatever you want to
call it's all the same thing not not all
strip clubs are fully nude a lot of
States it's illegal to be fully nude
they have to wear bras and panties
having a little kid pops around in his
underwear for money what do you think
you're doing
there are people defending that and they
say what's wrong with it I know a guy
who's a leftist I talk to him all the
time and he said what's wrong with sex
education and I said bro we're talking
about Chicago in the project Veritas
expose I said giving kids sex toys and
Lube is not sex ed that's Kink education
sex education is like here's the
reproductive parts of the body here's
what they do here's why they do it
here's what you need to know about
safety going to a kid and being like
here's a variety of toys whips you know
cattle nine tails or whatever you can
look at sick you can look at sex
education like a Chilton's book for like
a a car right sexual education is how it
works these are the body parts etc etc
once you start
describing sexual acts that sound like
you're selling a car that's different
you know it's like if you're trying to
to explain how to use use lube and stuff
like that that's that's trying to create
an Allure and and instruct kids about
pleasure and all the adult themes that
go along with sex if you're talking
about sexual education it's like you
know you can talk about the body parts
and talk about the functions and stuff
like that but to talk about you know
lube and stuff like that that's that's
enticing yeah it's enticing young adults
who are just learning about sexuality
I'm gonna make one more point on this
before we go into the next story because
I've made so many points about this but
uh you know Nuance bro have you read
this book I I'm familiar with the
genderqueer book did you read it I did
not read it but I'm familiar with what's
in it yeah um I got close to the end
I've read the whole thing so far but I
will just point out a few very important
things that people don't understand
about this book
the first thing everybody knows about
this book is that it was shown to
children and it has inappropriate images
of sexual activity among adults uh the
characters in it are in their 20s I
think at the time when they're engaging
in these activities they're showing
these explicit activities to children
and the author said in an interview it
should have been more explicit the first
thing people don't know about it which
many of you may know because you've
heard me say it Ad nauseam but I'll say
for those that aren't familiar is that
the intro to the story is this this
woman talking about her severe
psychological trauma abuse but it's
clear she doesn't understand she was
abused by her parents made to pee in the
yard when she was three years old she
couldn't read till she was 12. she would
wear dried old crusted pads with blood
flaking off of it which went to school
and she smelled so bad she got called
into the counselor and told you need to
learn basic hygiene my question is where
are her parents her parents were abusing
her what you discover in the end of the
book she explains that what she's doing
is actually her sexual fetish she is
aroused by being perceived as a man she
says it in the book and then it's like
interesting so it would seem that the
entire thing they're teaching children
is they want you to engage in the sexual
fantasies of other adults in day-to-day
life is it isn't that called
organophilia when you're turned on by or
is it oh that only one Auto androphilia
Andrews what she calls it so she's
aroused the thought of herself being a
man and
when so so you have to imagine when this
person is going around and saying call
me this call me this it's like are you
asking us to engage in your sexual
fantasy to arouse you
well and it's the same thing to Phil's
point if they're giving specific
descriptions of like sexual acts as
opposed to like here is how biology
Works they are making it so that we are
dominated by uh uh being compelled to
pursue sexual desire at all times and it
begins at extremely young age and it's
all the energy it's grooming and I think
what's sad about this is like to the
story about the the couple with the boys
and this book like
they are abuse and the fact that we are
not willing to be United on the front on
the front of like abusing children in
any capacity is bad is such a red flag
for our society it's so bizarre to me
that regardless of your political belief
you can't be like yes I am 100 Against
Child Abuse that's disturbing so so
where I'll bring these things all
together and then we'll jump to uh we'll
do a hard sideway is just when we're
entering this period where you are going
to have elements of our own law
enforcement existing in either world one
or World a you know because we don't
want to put anybody second you're a
world one or world day Futurama joke
then people are going to say outright
you're gonna have a cop saying like
that's an evil person there's gonna be a
cop on the other side saying no you're
the evil person because they both see
two completely different things
that's where we're going when we get to
the point where
right now it's Millennials gen xers are
close closer together uh baby boomers
are very close together in their world
views you can even look at the political
polling from Pew going back years and
where the overlap is between Democrat
Republican and as you get into
Millennial it starts bifurcating and
then gen Z completely bifurcated what
happens when Gen Z is in their 50s and
every generation below them is Universe
one Universe a well people are going to
be fighting each other physically
there's going to be no agreement there's
going to be no overlap it's going to be
quite literally you are evil period and
that's how you get into chaos thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time